in this final segment on predicate logic
there are two issues that I'm going to
talk about the first is some problems
with translating AE
quantifiers and ei quantifiers into
English rather from English into logic
we've seen examples in class that
English is ambiguous and I want to show
you two there I think interesting and
provocative just as a warning that the
translation is not always routine and
then the second topic is an optional one
just to kind of make some comments about
the amazing results in meta mathematics
the mathematics of mathematics or more
precisely the the mathematics of
mathematical logic and two fundamental
theorems about properties of predicate
calculus which go beyond this class and
are optional I would suggest it's worth
listening to the AE in English example
and if you want to skip the short
discussion of the meta theorems that's
fine because it's never going to come up
again in this class okay so let's look
at this phrase in English where the poet
says all that glitters is not gold well
a literal translation of that would be
that if we let G be glitters and I can't
use G again so we'll say au is gold
then this translated literally would say
for every X G of X if X is gold implies
that not gold of X all right so is that
a sensible translation well it's clearly
false because gold glitters like gold
and you can't say that gold is not gold
so this is not what's meant it's not a
good translation it doesn't make sense
well what is meant well when the poet
says all that glitters is not gold he's
really leaving out a key word to be
understood from context all that
glitters is not necessarily gold he's
using poetic
license you're supposed to fill in and
understand this meaning and the proper
translation would be that it is not true
that everything that's gold but
everything that glitters is gold it is
not the case that for all X if X
glitters then X is gold so it's just an
example where a literal translation
without thinking about what the sentence
means and what the the poet who
articulated the sentence intended will
get you something that's nonsense
it's one of the problems with machine
translation from natural language into
precise formal language okay let's look
at another example that of the same kind
the poet says this time there is a
season to every purpose under heaven
this is a variant of a biblical phrase
so what does it mean
well the literal translation would be
there exists an S that's a season such
that for every P that's a purpose S is
for P well that from the way that
quantifies work means that there's some
season say summer that's supposed to be
good for all purposes well that's not
right because summer is not good for
snow shoveling and if your purpose is to
shovel snow then summer will not do for
you as a season so even though it's
phrased there is a season to every
purpose under heaven it's not the case
that the intended translation is there
is a season for every purpose in fact
the poet really means to flip the
quantifiers which is what's shown here
we're going to switch him around so that
we are really saying for every purpose
there is a season such that s is for P
for snow shoveling winters good for
planting spring is good for leaf
watching fall is good and that is in
fact the intended translation here
although I remind you that there's a
famous historical man Sir Thomas Moore
who was described as a man for all
seasons
that would be a case where there was man
a one man who was good for all seasons
he was a polymath a writer a cleric and
the Chancellor of England for many years
until he had a falling out with Henry
the eighth
which served him ill okay that's the end
of those two examples whose point is
just to warn you that translation from
English from into math is not something
that can be done in a mindless
mechanical way sometimes the quantifiers
really are meant to go the other way
from the way that they literally appear
now we're gonna shift to another topic
which is just too profound theorems from
mathematical logic about the properties
of predicate calculus that are worth
knowing about and describe sort of the
power and limits of logic so these are
called meta theorems because they're
theorems about theorems they're theorems
about systems for proving theorems and
that phrase meta means you know going up
a level alright so the first theorem is
a good-news theorem it says that if you
want to be able to prove every valid
assertion of predicate calculus there
really is only a few axioms and rules
that will do the job as a matter of fact
the rules that you need are just rules
that you've seen already namely modus
ponens and universal generalization and
a few valid axioms which we've seen
already so let's go back a little bit so
there's a little mark here that says
that in practice if you're really going
to try to do automatic theorem proving
you need much more than this minimal
system but it's intellectually
interesting and satisfying that a fairly
economical set of axioms and inference
rules are in theory sufficient to prove
every logically valid sentence this is
known as girdle's completeness theorem
girdle was the great
mathematician German mathematician who
spent the latter part of his life at the
Institute for Advanced Study in
Princeton as an émigré and he has two
major theorems at least that are results
of his one is the completeness theorem
this one there's an incompleteness
theorem which maybe we'll talk about in
a few lectures but for now the good news
is you can prove everything that's valid
using a few simple rules okay
now the bad news is that there's no way
to tell whether your attempt to find a
proof for something that you think is
valid is going to succeed there's no way
to test whether or not a quantified
formula is valid this is in contrast to
the case of propositional formulas where
you can do with the truth table truth
table may blow up so it becomes
pragmatically infeasible but at least
theoretically there's an exhaustive
search that will enable you to figure
out whether a propositional formula is
valid that's not the case with predicate
calculus predicate calculus is
undecidable meaning that it's logically
impossible to write a computer program
that will take an arbitrary predicate
calculus formula in and print out true
or false depending on whether or not
it's valid can't be done now as I said
we're not going to go further into these
theorems they these are the kind of
basic results that would be proved in an
introductory course in logic usually
they take about a half a term to do
maybe a little less and it goes beyond
our course you can look over in the math
department for introductory courses in
logic and you will learn about these two
profound meta theorems about logic and
math